Les Jeux olympiques, du 26 juillet
au 11 août.
Les Jeux Paralympiques,
maintenant, du 28 août au 8 septembre.
C'est dans l'agenda.
En 2024, la France va accueillir un événement historique :
les Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques.
Comme vous pouvez le constater,
je suis dans les starting blocks
et je ne suis pas le seul.
La 7ème édition de la semaine
olympique et paralympique vient de
se terminer.
L'objectif de cet événement :
promouvoir la pratique sportive
et ses valeurs en milieu éducatif
de la maternelle à l'université.
C'est très important,
vous allez le voir, de pratiquer
une activité physique
que vous ayez des prédispositions ou pas.
Pour la santé, bien sûr, mais pas que,
c'est aussi un excellent moyen
de créer du lien social,
de lutter contre les discriminations
et de favoriser l'inclusion.
Je vous emmène aujourd'hui
à la rencontre de para athlètes
exceptionnels : Sofyane Mehiaoui,
qui pratique le basket fauteuil
en équipe de France et Nantenin Keïta,
championne paralympique du 400 mètres.
Et puis, j'ai également invité Michel
Cymès qui viendra nous parler
de sport et de santé.
Ça va être musclé !
Sofyane m'a donné rendez-vous au gymnase de Gennevilliers.
En attendant de représenter la France
aux Jeux Paralympiques de 2024,
c'est ici qu'il s'entraîne avec ses coéquipiers du club Hurricane 92.
Wow !
C'est physique, dis moi.
Vous vous entraînez souvent comme ça ?
Assez souvent parce qu'on
essaie de travailler en même temps
le cardio et en même temps
de se mettre en situation de match.
Et tout ça, c'est dans la prévision des J.O ?
On prépare les Jeux Paralympiques de 2024,
et pour ça, on a avant tout, le championnat du monde au mois de juin,
le championnat d'Europe au mois d'août
et un tournoi qualificatif
au mois de septembre.
Ça fait un programme très, très chargé.
C'est assez drôle parce que, moi, j'ai
pratiqué le basket quand j'étais jeune,
grosso modo jusqu'à l'âge de 20 ans.
Je te l'avoue,
je n'étais pas très, très bon
mais c'est un sport que j'adore.
D'ailleurs, quand j'ai commencé
mon métier de journaliste,
je commentais des matchs de basket.
Et, ce qui m'a le plus marqué
la première fois que j'ai assisté
à un match de basket
fauteuil, c'est la dimension du terrain.
Exactement le même terrain
que celui sur lequel je jouais.
Les terrains sont exactement les mêmes,
les distances à 3 points
sont exactement les mêmes,
la hauteur des paniers est aussi pareille,   3 mètres 05,
donc exactement pareil.
Je commence l'entraînement aujourd'hui, moi ?
Exactement, on y va, on se lance.
Essaie de t'installer.
Tout le monde peut jouer, qu'on soit handicapé ou qu'on soit valide.
Et c'est un sport qui est mixte car les filles et les garçons peuvent jouer.
Par contre, les personnes qui sont valides peuvent juste jouer
en championnat de France mais pas aux Jeux Paralympiques,
par exemple, ou en tournoi international.
Et, comment ce para sport, le basket fauteuil,
t'a permis de mieux vivre, de bien vivre, ton handicap ?
Ce sport, le basket fauteuil,
m'a permis de me dépasser,
de montrer aux autres
de quoi je suis capable de faire.
Ca m'a permis, vraiment, de montrer,
de démontrer que je suis un sportif et
que je peux faire des choses par moi même.
Voilà, tu t'es dépassé mais est-ce que
c'est aussi un facteur d'inclusion ?
Oui, aussi parce qu'entre nous, le fait que ce soit un sport collectif,
on n'est pas tendre,
on ne fait pas de cadeaux à l'autre.
Donc, tout de suite, quand on retourne
dans la vie classique,
on est un peu surprotégé.
Je suis une personne en situation de
handicap donc, du coup,
on ne veut pas forcément me faire du mal.
Quand on est dans l'association, justement, on est entre nous
donc on peut se moquer de nous,
on n'a pas de difficulté.
Si on tombe de son fauteuil, on rigole de la situation et ce qui est normal.
Il n'y a plus de barrière,
on voit plus le handicap.
Est-ce que l'arrivée
des Jeux Paralympiques,
à ton avis, a changé le regard du public
sur le handicap, sur les personnes
en situation de handicap ?
Oui, bien sûr
parce qu'on en parle de plus en plus.
On essaye, aussi, de comprendre le dépassement, le sport
et de ne pas essayer de juste comprendre le handicap.
Merci.
Merci, pour tout.
On l'a vu, avec Sofyane Mehiaoui,
pratiquer une activité sportive
quand on est en situation de handicap,
c'est possible et ça fait du bien.
Les Jeux Paralympiques sont
une compétition sportive qui se déroule
juste après les Jeux Olympiques
et à laquelle participent
des personnes en situation de handicap.
De manière tout à fait logique,
les athlètes paralympiques pratiquent
des para sports.
Il y a le para judo, le tennis fauteuil, le cécifoot ou encore le volleyball assis.
Il existe aujourd'hui, en France, une multitude de para sports,
collectif ou individuel.
Rien qu'aux Jeux Paralympiques de 2024,
pas moins de 23 disciplines seront représentées.
Aujourd'hui, toutes les personnes
en situation de handicap,
quel qu'il soit, peuvent donc trouver l'activité physique
correspondant à leur profil et à leur motivation.
J'ai rendez-vous avec Nantenin Keïta,
c'est l'une des para athlètes,
les plus talentueuses de sa génération.
Elle a été championne du monde sur 400 mètres en 2015, plusieurs fois médaillée
aux Jeux Paralympiques : en 2008, à Pékin,
en 2012 à Londres et en 2016 à Rio.
Je vais aller la rejoindre pendant une pause parce que sur la piste,
elle va un peu trop vite pour moi.
Bonjour Nantenin.
Bonjour.
Alors toi, ta discipline, c'est le para athlétisme
ou plus précisément le 400 mètres ?
Exactement.
Et alors, quand on te voit, l'aisance avec laquelle tu te déplaces sur la piste,
c'est très impressionnant.
On a même du mal à imaginer
que tu es malvoyante.
Alors moi, j'ai un handicap visuel, un handicap de naissance
parce que je suis albinos, et quand on est albinos, dans 99% des cas,
il y a une déficience visuelle
qui est accompagnée.
J'ai un champ visuel
qui est réduit parce qu'en fait,
j'ai beaucoup plus de facilité
à voir sur le côté que de voir en face.
Et, tu t'entraînes régulièrement ?
On est sportif de haut niveau
donc on a les mêmes exigences
que tout sportif de haut niveau.
Si les règles sont les mêmes, peut-être qu'on peut aller s'entraîner ensemble ?
Je t'invite à venir avec moi.
Voilà, tu vas me servir de coach.
Euh, ouais !
Ca va Nantenin ?
Ca va !
C'est quoi ton meilleur temps, en 400 mètres ?
Mon record, c'est 55 secondes 65.
Et comment ce para sport, justement,
t'a permis de bien vivre ce handicap ?
Le sport, et notamment le paralympique,
ça m'a vraiment permis
de prendre conscience que mon handicap
n'était pas une fin en soi.
Nantenin Keïta, c'est pas
qu'une personne déficiente visuelle,
c'est pas qu'une sportive de haut niveau, c'est les 2, en fait.
Et, à un moment donné dans ma vie,
je me disais que
si j'étais en situation de handicap,
si j'étais albinos,
si j'étais déficiente visuelle
forcément, ma vie, elle, serait pas bien, que je serais pas heureuse
dans ma vie parce que les gens me définissaient seulement
par cette apparence physique.
Et, en fait, le sport
m'a permis de me définir autrement
et notamment le sport paralympique.
Eh bien, écoute, nous, on a déjà passé
un très, très bon moment
en ta compagnie.
Que l'on soit ou non
en situation de handicap, faire du sport
ou pratiquer une activité physique,
nous aide à dépasser nos limites
tout en développant
nos capacités physiques et mentales.
Alors, cette idée n'est pas nouvelle.
Déjà, au Iᵉʳ siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
le poète romain Juvénal,
en faisait le constat,
c'est lui qui est à l'origine de cette
petite phrase que tout le monde connaît :
"Un esprit sain dans un corps sain".
Et pour parler de ce sujet, j'ai invité
un ami, un expert qui va nous expliquer
pourquoi faire du sport
ou pratiquer une activité physique,
c'est important pour la tête et
pour le reste du corps.
Salut Michel !
Salut Jamy !
Ca va ?
Ouais, très bien !
Alors, cher Michel, tu es médecin, ça,
tout le monde le sait,
tu fais également pas mal de sport
et tu es aussi Ambassadeur
Santé de Paris 2024.
Pourquoi est-il si important
de faire du sport
pour la santé physique et mentale, aussi ?
Les recommandations sont très précises,
elles ont été données
par l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé.
Tu sais, on parle souvent de faire 10000 pas, par jour. On oublie ça.
Surtout, il faut retenir 30 minutes
d'activité physique quotidienne
pour les adultes.
30 minutes pour les adultes, on recommande le double
pour les enfants, les plus jeunes.
Pourquoi tout ce temps
chez un enfant ?
Parce que c'est indispensable
et qu'on est dans une situation
catastrophique en France
sur le plan de l'activité physique chez les jeunes.
L'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
a fait un classement
sur, à peu près, 145 pays dans le monde, sur le niveau
d'activité physique des jeunes,
les jeunes enfants et adolescents.
Tu sais combien, on est, la France ?
On est 119ᵉ.
Donc, il y a un vrai problème en France,
il faut que nos jeunes bougent.
Les raisons pour lesquelles ils bougent
pas, on les connaît, les écrans.
On a tendance à être un peu flemmard
quand on est gamin et c'est indispensable
parce que c'est en bougeant
qu'on fait bouger
non seulement les muscles,
mais qu'on aide la croissance
et la densité osseuse.
Et puis, pour le moral, c'est aussi très,
très bien.
Des bienfaits que l'on retrouve également chez les adultes
et on dit aussi que les personnes qui sont
en situation de handicap
doivent pratiquer une activité physique.
Il y a des adaptations,
en fonction du type de handicap
mais ces personnes doivent impérativement bouger, également.
Tiens, si on allez se faire un petit tennis.
Ca m'a mis en forme ce petit tennis avec Michel.
Je vais poursuivre
l'entraînement à l'école,
j'ai rendez vous avec les élèves
d'une classe de CE2 de Clamart,
l'École Charles de Gaulle.
Bonjour, les enfants !
Bonjour !
Et, bonjour Florine.
On va apprendre à jongler
puis après à jongler
avec une mobilité réduite.
C'est beaucoup moins facile, hein ?
Alors, qui a gagné ? Où est le vainqueur ?
Bravo !
Nous allons faire une épreuve,
cette fois-ci, de football.
Puis après, de cécifoot.
Jamy ! Jamy ! Jamy !
Ouais !
Poteau droit.
Milieu.
Bravo !
Voilà, j'espère que cette immersion
dans les sports paralympiques vous a plu.
Comme vous avez pu le constater,
les para sports favorisent l'inclusion.
On peut tous les pratiquer, que l'on
soit en situation de handicap ou non.
Et je suis convaincu que maintenant,
après cette découverte, eh bien,
vous serez nombreux à venir
soutenir à mes côtés
les athlètes lors des Jeux Paralympiques de 2024 à Paris.
Allez à très bientôt, en petites foulées.